welcome back so i've started this video lecture
series on reinforcement learning and the last
three videos were at a very high level kind of
what is reinforcement learning how does it work uh
what are some of the applications but we really
didn't dig into too many details on the actual
algorithms of how you implement reinforcement
learning in practice and so that's what i'm
actually going to do today and in this next part
of this series is something i hope is going to be
really really useful kind of for all of you which
is the
The first thing is i'm going to kind oforganize the different approaches of reinforcementlearning
This is a massive field that's about100 years old
This merges neuroscience,behavioral science like Pavlov's dog, optimizationtheory, optimal control
think Bellman's equation
and the Hamilton Jacobi Bellman equation
all the way to modern day deep reinforcementlearning
which is kind of how to use powerful machine learning techniques to solve theseoptimization problems
and you'll remember that in my view of reinforcement learning
this isreally at the intersection of machine learning
and control theory
so we're essentially machinelearning good effective control strategies to interact with in a an environment
So in this first lecture what i'm gonna do and i think i'm hoping that thisis actually super useful for some of you
is i'm going to talk through the organization
of these different decisions you have to make
and kind of how you can think about the landscape
of reinforcement learning.
Before going on I want to mention this is actually a chapter in the
new second edition of our book data driven science
and engineering with myself and Nathan Kutz and
reinforcement learning was one of the new chapters
I decided to write so this is a great excuse
for me to get to learn more about reinforcementlearning
and it's also a nice opportunity for me
to kind of get to communicate more details to you
so if you want to download this chapter the link
is here, and I'll also put it in the comments below
and i'll have a link to the second edition of the
book uh up soon as well probably in the comments
good so um a new chapter you can
follow along with all of the videos
and each video kind of um you
know follows follows the chapter
good so before i get into that organizational
chart of how you know all of these different
types of reinforcement learning can be thought
of i want to just do a really really quick recap
of what is the reinforcement learning problem
so in reinforcement learning you have an agent
that gets to interact with the world or the
environment through a set of actions sometimes
these are discrete actions sometimes these are
continuous actions if i have a robot i might have
a continuous action space whereas if i'm playing
a game if i'm the you know the white pieces on a
chess board then i have a discrete set of actions
even though it might be kind of high dimensional
and i observe the state of the system at each
time step i get to observe the state of the system
and use that information uh to change my actions
to try to maximize my current or future rewards
uh through through playing and i'll mention that
in lots of applications for example in chess
the reward structure might be quite sparse i might
not get any feedback on whether or not i'm making
good moves until the very end when i either
win or lose tic-tac-toe backgammon checkers
go are all kind of the same way and that delayed
reward structure is one of the things that makes
this reinforcement learning problem really really
challenging it's what makes uh you know learning
in animal systems also challenging if you want to
teach your dog a trick you know they have to know
kind of step by step what you want them to do
and so you actually sometimes have to give them
rewards at intermediate steps to train a behavior
and so the agent their control strategy or their
their policy is typically called pi and it
basically is a probability of taking action a
given a state s a current state s so this could be
a deterministic policy it could be a probabilistic
policy but essentially it's a set of rules that
determines what actions i as the agent take given
uh what i sense uh in the environment to maximize
my future rewards so that's the policy and again
usually this is written in a probabilistic
framework because typically the environment
is written as a probabilistic model and there
is something called a value function so given
um you know some policy pi that i take then i can
associate a value with being in each of the states
of this system essentially by what is my expected
future reward add up all of my future rewards
what's the expectation of that and we'll put in
this little discount factor because future rewards
might be less uh advantageous to me than than
current rewards this is just something that people
do in economic theory it's kind of like a you
know utility function and so for every policy pi
there is a value associated with being in each
of the given states s now again i'll point out
for for even reasonably sophisticated problems you
can do this for tic-tac-toe you can enumerate all
possible states and all possible actions and you
can compute this value function kind of through
brute force but even for moderately complicated
games even like checkers let alone back game in
her chess or go this state space the the the
space of all possible states you could observe
your system in is astronomically large i think
it's estimated that there's 10 to the 80 plus um
maybe it's 10 to 180 africa it's a huge number of
possible chess boards even more possible go boards
and so you can't really actually enumerate
this value function but it's a good um kind
of abstract function that we can think about are
these policy functions and these value functions
and at least in simplistic dynamic programming
we often assume that we know a model of of our
environment and i'll get to that in a minute so
the goal here the entire goal of reinforcement
learning is to learn through trial and error
through experience what is the optimal policy
to maximize your future rewards okay so notice
that this value function is a function of policy
pi i want to learn the best possible policy that
always gives me the most value out of every board
position out of every state and that's a really
hard problem it's easy to state the goal and it
is really really hard to solve this problem that's
why it's been uh you know this growing field for
100 years that's why it's still a growing field
because we have more powerful emerging techniques
in machine learning to start to solve this problem
so that's the framework i need you to know what
the the policy is that is the set of kind of rules
or or uh you know controllers that i as an agent
get to take to manipulate my environment the value
function tells me how valuable it is to be in a
particular state so i might want to move myself
into that state so i need you to know kind of this
nomenclature so now i can kind of show you how all
of these techniques are organized okay so that's
what i'm going to do for the rest of the video
is we're going to talk through kind of the key
organization of all of the different uh like
like mainstream types of reinforcement learning
okay so the first biggest dichotomy is between
model-based and model-free reinforcement learning
so if you actually have a good model of your
environment you have some you know markov decision
process or some differential equation if you have
a good model to start with then you can work in
this model based reinforcement learning world now
some people don't actually consider what i'm about
to talk about reinforcement learning but but i
do okay so for example if my environment is a
markov decision process which means that there is
a probability kind of a deterministic probability
that sounds like an oxymoron but if there is
a specified probability of moving from state s
to the next state s prime given action a and
this probability function is known so it's a
it doesn't depend on the history of your actions
and states it only depends on the current state
and the current action determines a probability of
going to a next state s prime then uh two really
really powerful techniques that i'm going to tell
you about to optimize the the policy function pi
is policy iteration and value iteration these
allow you to essentially iteratively walk through
um the game or or the markov decision process
taking actions that you think are going to
be the best and then assessing what the
value of that action and state actually
are and then kind of refining and iterating
the policy function and the value function
so that is a really really powerful approach
if you have a model of your system you can
run this kind of on a computer and and kind of
determine learn what the best policy and value is
and this is kind of a special case of dynamic
programming that relies on the bellman optimality
condition for the value function
so i'm going to do a whole lecture
on this blue part right here we're going to
talk about policy iteration and value iteration
and how they are essentially dynamic using dynamic
programming on the value function which satisfies
bellman's optimality condition now that was for
probabilistic uh processes things where maybe
you know like backgammon where there's a dice
roll at every turn for deterministic systems like
a robot system or a self-driving car if i think
about a human you know my reinforcement learning
problem this is much more of a continuous control
problem in which case i might have some nonlinear
differential equation x dot equals f of x comma u
and so the linear optimal control that we studied
i guess in chapter 8 of the book so linear
quadratic regulators common filters things like
that optimal linear control problems are special
cases of this optimal non-linear control problem
with the hamilton jacobi bellman equation
again this relies on bellman optimality and
you can use kind of dynamic programming ideas
to solve optimal nonlinear control problems
like this now i'll point out mathematically
this is a beautiful theory it's powerful
it's been around for decades and it's you know
kind of the textbook way of thinking about how to
design optimal policies and optimal controllers
you know for markov decision processes and for
non-linear control systems in practice actually
solving these things with dynamic programming
ends up usually amounting to a brute force search
and it's usually not scalable to high dimensional
systems so typically it's hard to do this optimal
hamilton jacobi bellman type non-linear control
for an even moderately high dimensional system
you know you can do this for a three-dimensional
system sometimes a five-dimensional system maybe
you know i've heard special cases with with
machine learning you can do this maybe for a 10 or
100 dimensional system but you can't do this for
the nonlinear fluid flow equations which might
have you know a hundred thousand or a million
dimensional differential equation when you write
it down on your computer so important caveat there
but that's model based control and a lot of what
we're going to do in model free control uses ideas
that we learned from model based control so even
though you know i don't actually do a lot of this
in my daily life with reinforcement learning
most of the time we don't have a good model
of our system for example in chess i don't have
a model of my opponent for example or at least i
can't write it down mathematically as a markov
decision process so i can't really use these
techniques but a lot of what model free control
reinforcement learning is going to do is kind of
approximate dynamic programming where you're
simultaneously learning kind of the dynamics
or learning to update these these functions
through trial and error without actually having
a model and so in model-free reinforcement
learning kind of the major dichotomy here
is between gradient-free and gradient-based
methods and i'll tell you what this means in a
little bit but for example if i can parameterize
my policy pi by some variables theta and i know
kind of what the dependency with those variables
theta are i might be able to take the gradient
of my reward function or my value function
with respect to those parameters directly
and speed up the optimization okay so gradient
based if you if you can use it is usually going
to be the fastest most efficient way to do
things but oftentimes again we don't have
gradient information we're just playing games
we're playing chess we're playing go and i can't
compute the derivative of one game with respect
to another that's hard for me at least to do
and so within gradient free okay there's a lot
of dichotomies here there's a dichotomy of a
dichotomy of a dichotomy within gradient free
control there is this idea of sometimes you can
be off policy or on policy and it's a really
important uh distinction what on policy means
is that let's say i'm playing a bunch of games
of chess i'm trying to learn an optimal policy
function or an optimal value function or both by
playing games of chess and iteratively kind of
refining my estimate of pi or a v what on policy
means is that i always play my best game possible
whatever i think the value function is and
whatever i think my best policy possible is
i'm always going to use that best policy as i play
my game and i'm going to always try to kind of get
the most reward out of my system every game
i play that's what it means to be on policy
off policy means well maybe i'll try some things
maybe maybe i know that my policy is suboptimal
and so i'm just going to do some like random moves
occasionally that is called off policy because i
think they're sub-optimal but they might be really
valuable for learning information about the system
uh so on policy methods include this
sarsa state action reward state action
and there's all of these variants of the sarsa
algorithm this on policy reinforcement learning
and these tds mean temporal difference and mc
is monte carlo and so there's this whole family
of kind of gradient-free optimization techniques
that use different kind of amounts of history i'll
talk all about that that's going to be a whole
other lecture is this this red box gradient free
model free reinforcement learning and so the off
policy version of sarsa kind of this on policy
set of algorithms there is an off policy variant
called q learning and so this quality function
q is kind of the joint value if you
like of being in a particular state
and taking a particular action a so this quality
function contains all of the information of my
my optimal policy and the value function and both
of these can be derived from the quality function
but the really important distinction is that when
we learn based on the quality function we don't
need a model for what my next state is going to be
this quality function kind of implicitly defines
the value of you know based on where you're going
to go in the future and so q learning is a really
nice way of learning when you have no model and
you can take off policy information and learn
from that you can take a sub-optimal controller
just to see what happens and still learn and get
better policies and better value functions in the
future and that's also really important if you
want to do imitation learning if i want to just
watch other people play games of chess even though
i don't know what their value function is or what
their policy is with these off policy learning
algorithms you can accumulate that information
into your estimate of the world and every bit of
information you get improves your quality function
and it improves the next game you're going to play
so really powerful and i would say most of what we
do nowadays you know is kind of in this q learning
world a lot a lot a lot of machine learning is
q learning reinforcement learning is q-learning
and then the gradient-based algorithms i'm not
going to talk about it too much here but it's
essentially where you would actually update the
parameters of your policy or your value function
or your q function directly using some kind of a
gradient optimization so if i can sum up all of my
future rewards and it's a function of the current
parameters theta that parameterize my policy
then i might be able to use gradient optimization
things like newton's steps and steepest descent
things like that to get a good estimate
and this when i have the ability to do that
is going to be way way faster uh than any of
these uh these gradient free methods and and
even in term uh will be faster than dynamic
programming and so the last piece of this
is kind of in the last 10 years we've had this
massive explosion of deep reinforcement learning
a lot of this has been because of deep mind and
alphago you know demonstrating that machines
computers can play atari games at human level
performance they can beat grand masters that go
just incredibly impressive demonstrations
of reinforcement learning that now use deep
neural networks either to learn a model where you
can then use model-based reinforcement learning
or to represent these kind of model-free concepts
so you can have like a deep neural network for
the quality function you can have a deep neural
network for the policy and then differentiate
with respect to those network parameters uh using
kind of you know auto diff and back propagation
uh to do gradient based optimization on your
policy network i would say that deep model
predictive control this doesn't exactly fit into
the reinforcement learning world but i would say
you know it's it's morally very closely related
deep model predictive control allows you to solve
these kind of hard optimal nonlinear problems
and then you can actually learn a policy based
on what your model predictive controller actually
does you can essentially kind of codify that model
predictive controller into a control policy and
finally uh actor critic methods um actor critic
methods existed long before deep reinforcement
learning but nowadays they have kind of a renewed
interest uh because you can you can uh you
can train these with with deep neural networks
okay so that is the mile-high view as i see it of
the different categories of reinforcement learning
is this comprehensive absolutely
not is it a hundred percent
factually correct definitely not this is you
know a rough sketch of the main divides and
things you need to think about when you're
choosing a reinforcement learning algorithm
if you have a model of your system you can use
dynamic programming based on bellman optimality
if you don't have a model of the system you can
either use gradient free or gradient based methods
and then there's on policy and off policy variants
depending on you know your specific needs it tends
out to be that sarsa methods are more conservative
and q learning will tend to converge faster
and then for all of these methods there are
ways of kind of making them more powerful
and more flexible representations using uh deep
neural networks in kind of different focused ways
okay so in the next few videos we'll zoom into you
know this part here for markup decision processes
how we do policy iteration and value iteration
we'll actually derive the quality function uh here
we'll talk about model free control these kind
of gradient free methods on policy and off policy
cue learning is one of the most important ones and
temporal difference learning actually has a lot of
neuro science analog so how we learn in in our
animal brains people think you know is very
closely related to these td learning policies
we'll talk about how you do optimal nonlinear
control with the hamilton jacobi bellman equation
uh we'll talk very briefly about policy gradient
optimization and then you know all of these
there are kind of deep learning things uh
we'll pepper it throughout with deep learning
or maybe i'll have a whole lecture on on these
deep learning methods so that's all coming up
really excited to walk you through this thank you